The fruit of the cacao tree is a football-shaped pod that comes in a variety of colors.
Inside each pod is a sweet, white, fruity pulp that covers 50 to 60 seeds.
It is from these seeds that chocolate is made.
Once the pods are ripe, they are harvested in the same way they have been gathered...
...for thousands of years: by hand.
After collecting the pods, each one is split open.
Then the farmer scoops out the white pulp and separates the seeds,...
...commonly known as "cocoa beans."
The beans are covered with banana leaves or burlap while they ferment in the pulp.
After fermenting, the beans are uncovered and dried in the hot sun.
When the beans have achieved maximum dryness, it's time to go to market.
The farmer puts them in burlap sacks in which they will be sold...
...and shipped to chocolate factories around the world.